word of mouth marketing pub like that
and an neuromarketing where where the
use of brain scans and understanding of
how the brain works is being applied to
marketing I think those two areas while
well they're still nascent fields are
going to require regulation within the
next decade or two we're going to get to
a point where neuro marketers talk about
searching for the Buy button in the
brain and the idea is simply you know
how can we get you to buy means that
this is a for-profit relationship we
have with marketers and with the if the
intention is to sell goods if it's
whether it's with neuromarketing
understanding how your brain works what
photos what images what words work to
kind of shortcut your critical thinking
and go straight for your emotions or if
it's word of mouth it's you know
formalizing a campaign into a kind of
conversations and actually sending out
materials to groups of people who
essentially work for you I'm as part of
a community and we'll pitch these goods
to their friends their co-workers their
family whether it's teens or moms I mean
there's there's hundreds of thousands of
people in the US right now or a part of
formal word of mouth marketing campaigns
and 850,000 work for Procter and Gamble
which doesn't require them to reveal
their affiliation with the products they
pitch which are not just Procter &
Gamble products they're coca-cola
products or Toyota products or warner
music the connection is lost in in the
actual word of mouth campaign you don't
know sometimes that you're being pitched
these goods that it's not a genuine
organic recommendation and that's a
trust issue that's you know that's an
important thing we rely on word of mouth
whether it's online or in person to get
good products to find good services it's
buzz you know what's what's new what's
what's interesting
and when marketers can kind of find
their way into that that's that they
also please